321 kaufen
das ist nicht dein ernst
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
hey ho minecraft freunde willkommen zu
einer weiteren folge von montags meiner
wieder mal mit sky hd kunden ja mit
konkreter nicht wieder mal heute als
gast ist konkreter dabei als klammer
erklären was mache ich erkläre ich mal
ganz kurz was montags meiner ist es ein
neues prinzip was ich mir ausgedacht
habe hier ist auf jeden fall sehr gut
durch plant meinerseits
hier sehen wir schon die skins die dabei
sind hier in diesem komischen szene so
ein komischer fritz und ich mit der
sonnenbrille
leoni mit einem riesigen johannes gruppe
auf der anderen seite sehen wir das auch
noch mal hab ich nach laser augen und ja
das bin ich und hitler und komme
und das war bei ich hier sache vor
vor allem ich baue den hitlers kind ich
behalte ihn einfach mal vor zehn minuten
jetzt fängt an zu lachen
da habe ich gesehen auf der sonnenbrille
eine brille mit dem beispiel sich die
laugen alter jedenfalls muss ich ja
jetzt sachen bauen die ich vorbereitet
habe und die beiden müssen das erkennen
wir darum oder mal nicht in erster linie
töten und bei uns beiden geht es einfach
darum dass wir halt jeder für sich die
meisten punkte haben wollen das heißt
wir spielen ja so super und ich spiele
gegen dann da und man bekommt immer dann
ein punkt wenn man das was da gerade von
craft erbaut erraten hat innerhalb von
zwei minuten und borstel wären schön
stall mensch sich das überhaupt nicht
und jeder schon wieder los ok gomez zu
hilfe
das ist jetzt mal nur provisionsfrei
rasant jetzt eingefangen es schaltet ihr
kann raus wollen wir jetzt diesmal 200
mir ist es egal
zwei minuten ja wir zwei minuten
er kommt machen wir zwei minuten weil
wir wissen ja dass heute ist ono de
janeiro und gerade da brauchen wir mehr
aber ich hoffe du hast ja nicht so was
wie keeper mit vagina oder so nee nee
nee nee ich hab s adventure queen ist er
hat was dann mario mit penis nein nein
nein ich hab vernünftige sachen soll ich
anfangen einfach mal ja dann sagst aber
du sagst 3,1 blog also erstmal was ich
gerne zusammen los was ich dazu sagen
muss es ist es regnet gerade kurs halte
dass ein strichmännchen eine toilette
weil die figur rollt falsch wassereimer
schön komme dass du dich als steinmann
ich nicht das ist was da gesagt alle
lampe den regenschirm habe ich gemeint
alter das ist richtig ich habe dir nicht
mehr gemacht doch keine rolle ich war
gerne ring stehen machen ja es ist kacke
guck mal hier
ich wollte gerade so schön den
regenschirm bauen
das ist hier die zweite folge hallo ob
das ist der regel stimmt der deckt ihn
zwar nicht so richtig aber es ist
richtig
leute ich bin zwar noch ein wenig
erkältet damals sowas erkenne ich da
doch noch
ich hab den regen schon nicht mehr
gebaut worden und mensch in der waadt
regenschirm
das ist etwas mit regen zu tun hatten
ich ringe schirm ja so darauf ein
pfefferminztee
die zweite sache machen ja klar okay
zweite sache 31 von spongebob junge
richtig warum sagen hat kann doch nicht
sein ich kann hier nicht wird zu ende
behaupten so afl durstig es war dich ist
von sprossen
es war spongebob aber bitte bitte bei
jedem stopp daneben ganz ehrlich so klar
ich hab richtig sein dass es schnell
geht das kann doch nicht wahr sein dass
ich mit spongebob falsch das ist klar
weil er da oben eine sonnenbrille auf
sich aufgebracht hat man dann über die
kann man einfach immer direkt schon
erkennen was du sagst worden ist aber
wenig sich dort was vernünftige von
spö-kanzler niveau so dass es schon spaß
das ist kollege der bei manchen könnte
und mach ich habe gar nicht so viel vor
ich dachte braucht jahre erstmal um dies
zu erkennen um den regenschirm zu
erkennen oder als von spaß obwohl das
man dazu die einfachsten sachen jetzt
kommen sie etwas schwierigeren ok ok ok
kommen ich kann ich anfangen mit dem
nächsten jahr 321 kaufen aber das ist
nicht richtig
ja ich habe nie so mühe gegeben ich
wollte so schön mal was ist heute echt
bei hacks die ja ich verstehe gar vier
minuten ansage und wissen
minutenlang raten das wollte ich machen
ich dachte ihr sagt berg
und irgendwie satt und komm einfach als
er sich setzt einen frauen wollen blog
verkaufen
ich selbst auch noch einen blog aber
vielleicht wird man auch sagen irgendwie
auch vor kurzem musste demnach von taten
ist also gemacht warum denn du ich hab
schon du kannst ja ich mir vorüber wir
hier mit drei punkten spielen das spiel
mit 5
hier findet 7 sogar mit sieben spielen
kommen ja kleines spiel machen erst mal
war ich eben halt die klappe jetzt nach
ich bin mit sieben erstmal nicht weiter
gewinnst du nämlich spielen sieben ja
ich du kannst 321 blut regel fertig die
ersparnis schon schnell google
übersetzer ich bin hier schon über setze
ich meine internet ist wie langsamer als
dahin ausrufezeichen spanisch signo dem
irak ion ist wichtig man allerdings
macht sondern textseiten bildschirm auf
meine kappe da dachte ja für darf am
längsten braucht ich hab dann wie viele
punkte ich habe drei burke leute ich hab
drei punkte ich räume heute ab und ich
erwarte jetzt müssen wir ganz gut hier
noch sachen aus dem inventar holen
wie steht es denn jetzt grade von
punkten 13 punkte und skripte hat ein
punkt richtig 321
das sollte deutlichsten lauern berghofen
gesicht skin eigentlich kannst du es
jetzt noch gar nicht im klatenberg keine
ahnung ja keine ahnung ist richtig
in den filmen und schöne kleider alter
ein bildschirme treppe das ist eine
nacht keine zeit habe ich noch abstrakt
das gebäude noch ein gesicht und zwei
den clown ein konstrukt ein
parallelogramm jungs ich [ __ ] gab das
system alter ihr habt so nicht erraten
wolke sanduhr keine ahnung dunstabzug
soll wolke ist uns absolut wolkenstein
was eine eine krone eine ur rhein kanal
zeigt tafel sei es ist fertig
was ist das 99 und haufen dreck dass sie
das nicht erkennt alten verein ist das
ein verein so angucken ist das in
verschiedenen sichten ich erkennen da
wirklich gar nichts 99 euro und xbox
zeitlauf doch bitte ab ja du hast
bestimmt auch bei den lose kunst er darf
ich jetzt darf ich jetzt tipps geben
oder wie das jetzt werden nein komme ich
gebe euch jetzt tipps walter oder das
wäre witzig aber nicht so einfache tipps
programm
[Musik]
jetzt gehen nicht wieder auf google im
internet das gut 99 kilo
keine armee internet video auf und
weitete videoaufnahme als der junge das
ist das alter das öffnet wir jeden tag
also ich war mal wieder schneller
das ist so offensichtlich und wir kennen
das müsse so peinlich fand ich war schon
das ist echt peinlich leute schreibt mal
peinlich in die kommentare feineres
bäume peinlich weil ich auch immer mit
fraps aufnehmen vor allem komme geht
erst mal google
so dass dann irgendwas mit x90 kino oder
ich habe programm
was willst du okay 321 junge röcke penis
kampf wolken langsam finde ein gesicht
einen behälter ein eimer fahrrad gegner
vom creeper von t
ein bildschirm ein loch photoshop blau
mit 1 loch ein photoshop story ein
schneemann ein kräftiger firefox browser
chrome tipps gebe ich es gleich ein
blitz ein dreizack ein y titty 1play
wichtig aber war er weil erst hat der
city gesagt dann hat er gesagt sondern
im pcie longplay und danach die nebst
und late night place richtig wenn schon
altera vom mitmachen ich wirklich gut
getroffen ein foto 33 oder nein das ist
ja schon wieder
es fing so gut an so gut wirklich und
haben sie mal sehen nur weil du weil
hier konkret gemeint hast du mit frau
war hundertprozentig weil er gerne als
logo ein ja natürlich und erwarten wie
nur jahre schneller alter ja lichtjahre
110 km/h schneller als erwartet man ganz
sich überlegt nun ganz kurz wach weil
ich habe mir nicht so viel überlegt ich
reite auf die erde von geschlecht
so er ich hab es aber gleich was ich
bauen möchte
[Musik]
ich hab was okay ich liebe dich ja ich
bin ja ich muss eben noch das holen und
da muss ich mir noch das holen und jetzt
3 2 1 mcdonald's blog daumen nach oben
wasserkraft beleidigung fertig
[Musik]
vielleicht weiß nicht wie es bei uns
schon im bus war ein fisch ente war wo
wohnt die landesfahne firma jetzt nichts
mehr aus nach einer was ich habe echt so
eine ahnung hat ich habe einfach mal gar
kein plan davon
mein tipp erst wenn die zeit abgelaufen
ist wachmann mail schreibt mir mal weiß
kerpen tipp private ich schreibe dir was
gab macht wenig da kommt gleich so ein
spruch drauf steht bei skype warte warte
da steht was wer das liest ist es ist
das land mit platten gar nicht gut aus
gar nicht gut
ich werde auch nicht auf google
gruppendruck ich bewege komme schnell
geblieben der guckt mal google
ich habe genau nehme ich glaube der guck
ich bei google nicht
ihr müsst jetzt euch die ganze zeit
bewegen damit man sich das nicht okay
ich gebe euch weitere tipps ist 153
prozent der zuschauer bestimmten
facebook alter genau wie konntet ihr es
noch nicht wissen nähe dass ich doch
dass erst ein als ist auch wie schwer es
ist halt deutschlandflagge deutschland
bundesland deutschland thüring
saarbrücken des ehemaligen gerade google
nein ich bin die ganze zeit auf dauer
es ist die flagge des ehemaligen landes
braunschweig gekommen war schneller
er war nicht schneller aber sowas von
ich will dafür das logo haben es war das
war genauso ein grauen das war eine
ganze das war exakt worden das ist die
flagge des ehemaligen landes
braunschweigs natürlich weiß man dass
haye hat komme jetzt komplett gewonnen
ja alter das ist ja scheiße ich dass der
gewinnt ach komm du ich dachte ich kann
gewinnen ja eben hat was du bist sieger
der herzen ja das ja in bayern münchen
wenn es noch letzte folge habe ich
haushoch verloren diese folgen gut auch
es war ein knappes rennen muss man sagen
aber hey hey du bist du alter das muss
ich alles neu aufbauen
sorry ja bei mir war das die erste folge
montagsmaler wahrscheinlich auch die
letzte die nach diesen sachen die ich
mir geglaubt habt ja ja ich war viele
verbanden sich wie kommt man ganz
ehrlich ich schreibe einfach mal an
scheiß schwachsinn sachen volt auf
meinem keller ist voll die beleidigung
ja macht immer die verabschiedung ich
komme nicht mehr für server doch du
kommst du darauf war eine wunderschöne
frau wir stehen ja eine menge spaß
gemacht wirklich also so viel spaß war
erst die zweite folge aber ich wollte
gerade schon sagen so viel spaß hatte
ich in dieser staffel noch nie
es heißt widerstand wird mit i
geschrieben nicht mit ihnen negation was
laberst du dich schuldig so langguth
dann wäre es das habe ich die folge
leute wirklich an der stelle sagen
konkreter vielen dank an sich das
desaster von crafter noch mal dabei war
oder in der vierten staffel dann
schreibt das einfach bei uns genau
und dann haut er eine bewertung würde
uns beide sehr freuen und schön und drei
eigentlich nicht
das fällt auf dass die punkte hier
vergeben war bewahrte wartet komme hat
die folge zwei was bekomme ich für block
romandie ja natürlich via blog leute
sollen wäre das für die folge hatte ryan
bewertungen wie gesagt welt cool und
dann schön mit
[Musik]